[Musique]
l'époque d'internet de l'époque
à l'époque il n'y avait pas les bons on
va commencer en fin d'année répète et
après on film totalement troué en direct
sur tf1
c'est faux c'est pas vrai on enregistre
leur avantage après allez vous aimons à
200 recommence pas bon je te mets care
soin de cacher tous les boutons pour la
cdc avec les pattes ça donne un mal
est-ce qu'on entendrait le rejoigne mans
[Musique]
du coup pas du coup tu montres se raser
c'est pareil qui a deux minutes séparent
elle met à ce qu'il n'y aurait pas deux
comme le produit à bobino où je tape
assez normal ça arrive avec cette
moustache
je vais pas rigoler au maximum je garde
la moustache du monde binaire
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie je
suis jeté à leur lourd ce qu'on va faire
si tu venais faire une petite chanson
tout affrontera qu'est allé c'était pas
mal d'amour on peut l'applaudir
je fais un bruitage dessin animé saleh
d'avoir 40 50 et d'être là specter
gordon accessoirement est également le
fils caché de nstein 5 htv été conçu
pour cacher de ne pas le voir s'ils
croient c'est le train direction de
coire
[Musique]
c'est un moment c'est tout
la bâtisse est le mec qu'on est le plus
loin possible
ça fait toujours plaisir je repère est
là avec les 4
finale ça se saurait
daniel fois
hurd canal saint martin
mr
[Musique]
et dans le casque est ya pas de vache tu
es au plus fort des choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lumière leurs actions
[Musique]
pascual ah bon mais rhône cellule c'est
l'âme ce qui se passe au québec ce soir
c'est ma soirée
tu veux me voir sur scène mais pas de
souci vient vraiment spectacle norman
sur scène que je joue actuellement dans
toute la france et je dois aussi à paris
au palace à partir du 15 octobre 2015
pour prendre directement ta place eh
bien tu cliques sur le petit lien dans
la description tout simplement tu verras
je suis hyper marrant c'est abusé